What's up everybody!
We are Pongfinity
Today we are playing Jenga battles
We are going to see
Whose tower makes it the highest!
Rock-paper-scissors who gets to start
The loser will face a punishment at the end!
That's 2 for me
You almost got one from this side!
Double shot again!
That's unfair!
I will also start doing doubles!
Miikka won!
No, you have to get 1 more
We are even right now
True!
Winner!
I'm going to win this one!
Let's take that one then...
Did I get it?
Yup!
I can already say that I won't lose this battle!
Good job!
The tower is looking great!
Looking a bit dodgy, Otto.
Go for it!
Actually it's even right now
I have to get one more
How many blocks was that?
That's a draw!
You can start
You still have to get 1 more block!
The winner!
Emil, that was so bad!
It still won't fall!
It's all about the building!
Good match!
That means Miikka won.
I guess we will have to take a re-match
To see who is the loser
I think that the last match was so bad from
you Emil
That you lost the whole tournament
Otto lost the re-match...
I have made a tower...
Otto gets to keep it on top of his head
I'm not sure if it's going to stay there
Voilá!
Are you trying to hit me?
That's one!
First one!
Wow, second one!
This is going better than the actual game!
I wasn't even aiming at the tower
I think that was 4 or 5 blocks
You did a good job!
Thanks for watching guys
This was Jenga battles
Leave your comments and ideas
For the next battle we should do!
Until next time!